they did my measurements for the
costumes they bring me a pair of pants
that is a size
58 waist and um these are like
way too big and they're like well it's
just the biggest ones they had
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast i am
your host your roast coming queen
a girl who would always dye the ends of
her hair
purple and then get it all over her ears
and then just kind of show up to school
that way
elise morales and with us today
guys we have such a fun guest
dare i say one of my favorite people uh
a comedian a drag artist
a content creator from do you know from
benches you know him as fat carrie
bradshaw
but before all of that he was a graduate
of shaker
high school it's chris burns
hello hello wow a drag artist a drag
artist oh um fancy
that's you know what there's artistry
honestly i love it thank you
nobody's called me before well you heard
it here on this podcast
an artist i'm adding it to my instagram
bio as we speak
okay chris i like to start out uh
the podcast and i ask all of my guests
the same question which is
was your high school public or private
public
please private school absolutely not
were there
any notable private schools in your area
there was so actually um paige de sorbo
from
bravo summer house would have went to
high school with me but she went to
private school so there was like um
there were several there was two like
really big ones for boys
and then there was two really big ones
for girls that were private
and did you interact with the private
school kids at all or were they
completely in a separate world i had
like
some friends who were like dating boys
from the private schools
but i never really interacted with
any of the private school people because
i was like um
i i they were very like lax browy the
boys yeah
so i was terrified of them so no i never
talked to them
what was your social positioning at
shaker
would you say how would you describe w
where you
fell how i like to describe
myself so junior high was my real prime
um like i felt like i was kind of a
loser in elementary school junior high
came i was very popular
you know um but then in ninth grade is
when people start like learning what gay
is and things like that
at least back in our day and so i feel
like that's kind of when i started
losing them
um so in my mind
i was like have you seen the 30 rock
episode when like they show tina fey's
flashback
and she's talking about how she was such
a nerd and it comes
and she's like well at least my mom's
not a pill addict or whatever i feel
like that was kind of my situation where
i'm like
i was bullied but then also i think
about a lot of things that i didn't said
to other people and i'm like was i
a bully i was like desperate to not be
that i was like very much i wanted to
fit in and be um like normal and stuff
so
it was an interesting time and then
i mean i've talked about this i think on
your live shows before
but i figured you know that
the musical theater program would be
where someone like me would fit right in
but i was
very wrong and to this day i won't rest
until i shut down the musical theater
program
at shaker high school so let's
this is what i've been waiting to get in
when i when i booked you
on the show this is the exact topic i
wanted to get in with
with you so let's talk through
what happened with your high school
theater program
okay so it all started ironically in
junior high where again i was very
popular
and so in seventh grade my
primarily white high school did the wiz
um a classic move
with looking back i'm like that was an
odd choice
but um like i think 200 people
auditioned
they took i think like 130 and then
there was an alternate list of
20 and then there was a um stage crew
list
of 20. i was not on
any of the lists so what is that that's
a hundred
it was literally probably like they
didn't take like 20 people
out of the 200 that audition like at the
point where when i went to see the show
like they had members from like the
chorus
um like aligning the
the stairs and stuff because there were
so many people in it the stage is
overflowing
with students that they've allowed in
and it was
literally overflowing with these
husbands uh
singing and like even my close friends
like
my best friend growing up lived like two
doors down and she didn't care about
musical theater she got a speaking role
if you have any inkling of why
you were not chosen to such a degree
do you remember your audition at all i
remember
most of my auditions um from that all of
these times
there was one and i can't remember if it
was for the wiz
which was seventh grade or anything goes
which was eighth grade
i do remember i think it was for
anything goes so this was the next year
and i was like i'm gonna
blow them out of the water for this
because they didn't want me for my whiz
so they're gonna get me before anything
goes and um
i got on the alternate list i was 15th
on the alternate list
so you were moving you did improve so i
improved slightly and i remember being
like i'm on the alternate list and i
remember
saying it out loud when they posted it
and the girl next to me was like
pretty far down and i was like
you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] these are vicious
[ __ ]
i'm like you how dare you and again it
was like 180 people but i did get in
i would have tonya harding my way into
that
i was ready and in that audition i fake
passed out
in the scene which it did not call for
and i
remember the director was like
okay why don't you get up great thank
you
and i remember being like should i have
not have passed out
what was the scene was it from anything
goes
i think it was from anything goes i was
supposed to be really mad i think
looking back maybe the scene didn't call
for a passing out
i was like listen i would rather give
you too much and then you can bring me
back in
you know exactly but regardless so
then we come to high school which now
theater is gay over the summer everyone
has learned that kids that are into
theater
are gay um so it's a much smaller pool
of
males auditioning and so
we did ninth grade was footloose
okay and so i auditioned and i got um
the role of chorus uh
okay we've moved into the cast now we've
been cast
and i was like oh my god i got into the
chorus and another this [ __ ] brianna
was like
yeah cause you're a guy any guy that
auditioned got in and i was like
okay brianna because it doesn't seem
like your name's on the list and that's
why you're coming for me i understand
but regardless um but then it turned out
that everyone
hated me i like to this day i still do
not know why everyone in the musical
theater program hated me
and like literally i want to be like
what what was what's the t like why
did this occur and they split the chorus
so there was adults
and um teens it was like three quarters
of the course was teens a quarter was
adults and the teens are the ones
doing the dancing and the chorus is the
one that comes or the adults come out
like twice and are just like stop
dancing and sing like
um choir so of course i was uh
an adult and this was when
they did my measurements for the
costumes
and they bring me a pair of pants now
let me tell you something i am
a size like 40 waist now they
and i regardless they bring me a pair of
pants that is a size 58 waist
and i'm like these are like way too big
and they're like well it's just the
biggest ones they had and i was like
did you look at any other options or you
just went with the biggest ones that
they
had and then uh they didn't have a belt
so i had to like tie the pants with
twine
for yeah you know just like a
a a local adult who has giant pants
and he's dying with ropes obviously i
can't feel confident in this [ __ ]
so that was the wiz or that was a
footloose the next year 10th grade they
do
once on this island again my primarily
white high school
that's crazy i played a tree
um and everyone hated me i think because
i didn't commit enough to the
being a tree is the only thing because i
remember like
it was being talked about how i wasn't
committing to being a tree
and i was like i don't know how to deal
with this situation
did you okay well here's the question
though were you like i'm gonna pass out
as the tree
this giving it was a windstorm in my
mind
the tree was blowing okay
um and then
junior year they did fame which again
i got chorus um but
i was an exchange student in germany for
three weeks so i missed like the first
three weeks of rehearsal
and then i found out when i got home
that i had a
tumor in my knee so i had to like have
it removed so i was like i'm just gonna
quit the show and i was expecting like
some sort of drama you know maybe like
uh
oh my god you know like bring him in as
someone in a wheelchair
there was none of that i um i don't
think
i even received an email back when i
quit the show
um there was just an impromptu cast
and then the crucible i thought that i
had gotten the role of
um giles corey who dies so like she
called
and was like i'd like to offer you the
role of willard and in my head
willard was giles cory and i was like oh
my god i get to have a dying scene on
stage
like unreal believable and then on the
first day of rehearsal we get the
scripts and i'm like
oh i have one line and it is um
willard only appears in like some
versions of the crucible because it's
so expendable and it's literally like
when tituba is like
freaking out in the jail cell and having
her like
whatever you know which experience i
like going i'm like quiet down
i mean here's the thing though i am
as painful as this journey was from for
you i am inspired because you did go
from one of 20 not
to be allowed to be participating in the
performance at all
too the named role
of willard yes i
i really did i got there and you know
when you have a role that
is often cut from the show
that is actually that is actually a
blessing because you don't have the
baggage of
all those other performances weighing
you down
exactly you can bring whatever you want
to willard
precisely um and that's why i retired
and i didn't audition for anything
senior year
um but to this day i want to give the
i can't wait to one day give a
commencement speech at shaker
and i'm gonna be like let me tell you
about who i hate and
call out the theater program by name
you're like look at me i'm a star and
they missed me
actually the one teacher that always i'm
like you don't see my star quality
um he would like speak over my auditions
as he was playing piano like talking to
other people and i was like i can't wait
to show him and then last year he
[ __ ] like died suddenly and i'm like
don't they always he would rather die
than deal with me
fine he would rather die early than see
your rise to fame
[Laughter]
well well well if it isn't
today's episode of the podcast which is
brought to you
by mint mobile breaking up with your old
wireless provider just got a whole lot
easier thanks to
mint mobile they were the first company
to sell premium wireless services online
only and now
mint mobile is introducing their
unlimited data plan for just
30 bucks a month let that sink in an
unlimited plan
for 30 bucks how much is your soon to be
x wireless provider charging you
for people that hate their phone bill
and are ready to cut ties with big
wireless
mint mobile offers their premium
unlimited plans for just
30 bucks a month going online only and
eliminating the traditional costs of
retail
mint mobile passes significant savings
on to you hun all planned i don't know
why this ad has become sexy
but that's what's happening all plans
come with unlimited talk and text
plus high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g
network use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan
and keep your same phone number along
with all
of your existing contacts and if you're
not 100
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their seven-day money-back
guarantee
break up with big wireless and switch
to mint mobile's premium unlimited data
plan
for 30 bucks a month when people who
complain about like me having vocal fry
i imagine that that's what they want me
to sound like
to get your unlimited wire plan for just
30 bucks a month and get your plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
teen self that's mint mobile.com
teamself cut your wireless bill to 30
bucks a month at
mintmobile.com team
south today's episode of the roast of
your teenage self podcast is
brought to you by trivia star do you
enjoy challenging yourself with trivia
if you're one of the people who always
knows the answer
test your knowledge with trivia star
trivia star is a
free mobile quiz game that's
entertaining and challenging
you can choose categories like music
sports movies tv animals celebrities and
over 60 other categories to choose from
so there's
always more trivia to explore i think
i'm going to commit to this voice for
the rest of the ad
if you choose the correct answer from a
multiple choice and beat the clock you
move on to the next level
the questions get harder over time but
don't get but don't worry
if you get stuck you can use coins and
gems to get a hint and beat the level
and trivia star has two
thousand five star reviews in the apple
store join them today and see if you're
smart enough to win i sound smart
because
i'm british right now trivia star is
offering you
2 500 coins and 500 gems
when you download and play just go to
the apple or
google store and search for trivia star
again search
trivia star and enjoy 2 500 coins
and 500 gems download trivia star
for free today sir today's
episode of the roast of your teenage
self podcast
is brought to you by purple
throw some betting on a bunch of
different mattresses and sure they all
look the same and the same goes for
pillows but
peel away the layers and look at what's
inside and you'll see
they're not all created equal and that's
what makes every purple pillow and
mattress unlike
anything you've ever slept
on before true story i i slept through
my alarm today
slept through it had to wake up early
had stuff to do
didn't get it done because i slept
through my alarm and you know why it's
because the purple grid
sets purple mattresses apart from every
other mattress
and its patented comforted technology
instantly
adapts to your body's natural shape and
sleep style with over eighteen hundred
open air channels designed to neutralize
body heat
purple provides a cooling effect that
other mattresses
can't replicate and this cutting edge
technology
doesn't stop with the mattresses every
purple pillow
is engineered with the grid for total
head and neck
support and absolute airflow so you're
always on the cool side of the pillow
purple's proprietary technology has been
innovating comfort for over
15 years and now we've come
to the part of the ad where i talk about
you hear my chair where i talk about my
sweaty hot bed
and my giant big old wisconsin fiancee
that makes my bed all hot
and and everything gets sweaty and it's
nasty
but not anymore because of the purple
pillows cooling effects and you can try
every
purple pill you can try every purple
product
risk free with free shipping and returns
and purple has financing available for
as low as 0
apr for qualified customers so
experience
the purple grid and sleep like you've
never slept before
go to purple.com teen self
10. that's t e e
n s e l f and then the number 10
and use promo code teen self 10 for a
limited time and you'll get 10
off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com
teen self 10 promo code teen self 10 for
off and you get the order of 200 or more
terms apply
so what was your level of partying
at that time because i think we do have
a picture of you
where you appear to be at a party yeah
pull that up so you two people
were um she was a close friend of mine
this was i think my senior year actually
um
and i drank a lot
and this was also when i very first
started trying weed and so this was the
first night i did both in the same night
um they actually are married with two
kids
you now them by being cross-faded in
their presence
and um we don't speak anymore but they
seem happy online
um the real thing was when i woke up
from this
and i was like i don't this was my
friend
older friend's apartment so i worked at
a grocery store
in high school and so i was like hanging
out with like 30 year olds and going to
their
apartments that they had by themselves
and um i woke up and i was like uh
what's wrong i don't know what this
feeling is and the first time i ever
threw up it was projectile
i'm telling you vomiting through the
window behind her
um but i never picked the screen up
so it was like a net basically
so you just slammed it was a [ __ ] hit
the fan situation but it was the vomit
hit the screen
very literally yes i feel like those
early like drinking vomits were so
violent and i thought i was dying
i literally was like the devil's coming
out of
me sometimes i'm like i wish i could go
back to high school
for like a day but like as who i am now
to be like
really none of this matters you
literally can't actually tell me what to
do
um no i'm not going to do the physical
fitness test and
embarrass myself in front of the whole
school like there's so many things that
i'm like
why did i just do those things i have
that fantasy
all the time of like going back
and being like actually i'm better than
all of you
yeah we should write a movie that's uh
back to school for a while but you go
back as yourself
now yeah and i'm just like move
you know what's really sad like one of
the main things that i would do
and truly in my heart is i would go back
and crush my baker's wife
audition because i got too nervous and i
biffed it and i ended up not getting a
good part
into the woods and it really has weighed
on my soul
and and so sadly i do think that number
one thing on the agenda for my one week
back in high school as myself now is to
just go
[ __ ] crush that banker's life
audition although i imagine we go back
as we are now and then just immediately
fall back into the tropes of high school
yeah
someone else gets cast as willard
they're like i don't know what's going
on with christmas
you lit you're demoted a bigger loser
than i was before
yeah i don't get to have two boyfriends
i have zero boyfriends
let's talk about gayness so um
were you out in high school at all
where no but um i didn't come until i
was 22.
were you out to yourself like
i think like things started
becoming clearer around like 15 16
but i like so badly didn't want to be
and
like i hadn't met anybody that was like
in my life
other than like my friend's uncle who
would come into town once in a while
yeah um when i realized i'm like this
can't be normal it's like when i first
started watching porn
and i googled like how to mute just the
girl and
how to erase the girl in porn and turn
the girl into another guy
and i'm like not gay it's just like her
screaming is annoying
um i'm sorry can you hear that yeah
there's like a little something in the
back
i'm at my parents house and when i'm
recording they're like okay great we'll
be quiet and then go out and lift the
garage door up five times
um but it wasn't until like after
even i was like i think junior
[Music]
junior year between junior and senior
year of college i was like i think i'm
bi
and i told like a couple of friends um
and then after i graduated i was like
obviously i'm not so um
but in high school everyone else thought
i was yes if that if you were gonna ask
um did people believe it no uh and
everyone talked about it behind my back
all the time
cool okay so at what point did the
school
starts because you were saying like at a
certain point everyone was like
well chris burns is gay when did like
you're like
you know you know when someone's talking
[ __ ] about you yeah and i wasn't gonna
call anyone out on it because i didn't
want to have that conversation
um but i remember when i was like 13 my
friend again the one that owns the
liquor store and i were like walking and
she's like
i heard my aunt susan and my mom talking
and they both think you're gay
and i was like goddammit aunt susan
and i was like well that's weird i'm not
why would they think that and she was
like i don't know honestly i think it
too
and i was like that's weird i'm not so
um
yeah it's so interesting to look back at
like the
where gay issues were at the time when
we were growing
up because like obviously
there was no like right to marriage at
that time and i feel like
i feel like in high school in middle
school
and earlier everyone had like called
stuff gay and been like oh that's so gay
and like all of that
like stupid yeah when gay like like
gay as in stupid exactly and then
something happened honestly i think like
i started listening to punk music and
the iraq war happened and i like became
a little
a little leftist and and then i became
the girl who was on the bus he was like
you actually shouldn't say gays and
stupid because that's actually really
bad
and yeah yeah and i would like
if somebody said that i'd like because
i'm like i can't have any
uh suspicions and then this one kid did
come out
and he actually i guess
was going around school being like
there's so many closet cases in this
school it was like listing
the people that were closet cases
ironically he was right about all of
them and
everyone that he said is now gay but at
the time i was like i would rather die
than anybody know that like literally
never ever ever will i say that and i
don't
i mean i hope obviously like homophobia
still exists but i don't think it's the
same for these
gen z no now it's like we're like
it's you're more popular uh janie my
friend or you know janie
um she was like mentoring kids years ago
in the city before she moved but uh
there was like a 15 year old girl that
she mentored who was like so upset
because her friends
were like making fun of her because she
was straight
and she was like i wish i could like
like both
genders but i just don't and they don't
and i'm like
what a world we live in now i mean
hey the pendulum's got to swing the
other way a little bit
but let's look through the rest of your
pictures
before we end i think we have some
okay so this was the very first
like uh modeling photo okay and my
friend danielle
we can see i was 15 um
made me take this picture and i remember
being like wow look at me i am
very angsty where are you
what are you leaning up against there
was our my elementary school playground
so my elementary school was like
walking distance from my house and when
we were there it was like a huge
wooden playground it was like very
impressive and the whole like town had
built it together
and then this kid i graduated with older
brother got drunk and burned it down
[Laughter]
and so like you do that was when we were
in high school and so they rebuilt it so
this was
the rebuild day i i did a couple
like uh playground photo shoots of my
own
and uh it's very like
you have playgrounds when you're a kid
and then there's a resurgence of
playgrounds in your life as a teenager i
feel
yes for sure and yeah i mean there's
a lot more stories from that playground
but we'll save those for another day
was it was that a good like getting
drunk spot
um yes so once i was there with friends
and
the cops came but you weren't allowed to
be there after dark because somebody had
burned it down previously
okay fair we weren't we weren't drinking
but we ran
and the cops like all chased us and it
was this whole thing but long story
short
um i fell the second the cops got there
running down the hill because it's all
woods around it
i fell and landed face first in the
woods and i
just was like i'm just gonna lay here
and hope they don't find me
and four hours later i was still laying
there but they caught all other 13
people i was with and i was the only one
that didn't get caught and i remember
them standing
literally like the cop was next to my
head
with his flashlight what is happening
sorry that's so that like reminds me of
the first scene of handmaid's tale where
she's like
hiding from like the gilead off
literally and
for like four hours and i was home like
hours late
than i was supposed to be but i never
got caught
did you have a strict curfew how were
your parents on that
i didn't really break the rules but it
wasn't like
because my i would be like i met kate's
who lived two doors down so it would be
like
you know be home by like 11 or midnight
on the weekend
yeah see my parents weren't like i
didn't really have to construct
elaborate
lies or sneak out i would just be like
i'm staying at megan's and they weren't
like
the type to call and like make sure that
that's actually working yeah i didn't
want
that benefit because i had no like male
friends
and i wasn't allowed to have sleepovers
at my female friends
um so i never got to like really
that is tough wow i like that but
you know hindsight's 20 20. and that's
why it's so sad that you and the other
uh like closeted gays at your school
couldn't form an alliance
because you could have all said you were
sleeping over each other's houses okay
let's go through to your next picture
okay perfect is this prom this is prom
okay so this is actually junior prom
but i was a sophomore and
that's my friend steph and her older
sister
was a year older than us and so their
group of friends like
two of them needed dates so her and i
went um
and that kid ironically
um is paige de sorbo from summerhouse's
cousin who i graduated oh
and we were not friends at all but he is
gay now as well
as you can see so all the men in this
photo are now gay
yes and were gay but just didn't feel
like saying it
um yes very much but yeah this was i
i paid like 250 for that suit
wow and that's what
you do look i don't know there's a lurch
quality
to some like adam's family stuff going
on yes look at that hair
i mean come on once uh someone told me i
looked like a big brown
um q-tip because of my hair because it
would i never i thought putting gel in
my hair would make people think i was
gay so i didn't
so were you also because obviously now
like you
ha you do you like great nail looks
great
like makeup looks all that stuff did
were you able to have any fun with your
fashion at all then or were you just
like
it was a north face jacket every single
day
and was that partially because you were
like i don't want anyone to think
that i am gay yeah i was like i cannot
be fashionable
i would not ever and no i mean and i
remember being like
seeing nails of like cashiers and being
like wow
everyday even because my mom is like one
of
like she only has brothers she only has
sons um
so even my mom was like i do not under
like she's like i would never pay to
have my nails done i don't understand
fake nails or why anyone would want them
so i'm like i didn't grow up around that
either so it was like a
uh it was pure it's a pure love
straight from your gayness literally i'm
like
nature versus nurture
all right um do we have another photo i
think there's
oh here i am being a bro okay so this is
you
attempting to look straight and i
honestly actually think you're doing a
great job in this one i
thank you so much and also this says
2005 but i really think that's wrong i
think this is like 2008
because that kid i didn't become friends
with until
um i was working at the grocery store
well i guess
it could have been because i was 16. no
i was 15 when i started working at the
grocery store so i guess i didn't know
and then
um and i like secretly had a crush on
him and he came to my friend's high
school party because he went to a
different school and then he ended up
having sex with her
damn he is cute he's got the swoop hair
and at the time it was very uh i mean
2005 is peak year of the swoop
haircut and it looks like he really has
the face for it too
he did he was a cutie patootie but how
could he have even
how could he have even known because
you're so successfully pulling off
straight here with a backwards cap
which i think is his hat i think i'm
wearing his hat
the most flirtatious moment in anyone's
life
is to take and wear their crush's hat i
know right and then he went and slept
with my friend
who's standing behind him whose wedding
i was in
but she's been divorced since so there's
a lot happening in this room there's a
lot
okay chris this conversation has been
amazing
i feel like we've gotten a a beautiful
picture
of you as a youth i we like to end the
show
with one final question which is if
you could tell team chris
anything what would you tell him
um i feel like
there's so many lame things that i want
to say and there would definitely
be like just come out sooner and blah
blah and um
i think my biggest thing would be like
to not be afraid of confrontation
and like stand up for yourself in high
school
because there was like some hoes there's
still people that i'm like i should have
knocked that [ __ ] down and i live with
that regret there's like one girl
who lives in new york and to this day
i'm like i want to bump into her and
still tell her often it has been like 15
years
you know what those people that really
really do a number on you though they
get you
and it's a valuable lesson like don't
let people be [ __ ] mean to you
yeah so say what you want to say that's
what i will say also
stop wearing so many undershirts because
it doesn't help you look less fat
beautiful beautiful practical
emotional incredible advice
chris aka fat carrie bradshaw thank you
so much for doing the show
yeah what a dream and for everyone at
home this has been the roast of your
teenage self podcast
you